everybody Welcome to the second Talk of
the day so our next speaker is under
Kelly and he's going to talk about
strong bounce for expected progressions
of size three so take it away sure yeah
so thanks so much for the invitation to
come give the talk uh this is about the
joint work with Raghu Mecca
and okay so a three-term arithmetic
progression uh what that is is a just a
triple of three numbers that are like um
evenly spaced like this so
um equivalently there's some solution to
this simple linear equation X Plus y
equals 2z
um and you know it's like a trivial
three progression when X and Y and Z are
the same but um
uh if any two of them are different then
all three of them are different and um
we get a non-trivial three progression
so
there's a very well-known theorem uh due
to Raw which says that um
if you have a set
within the integers one through n with
no other property about it besides that
it's dense enough then actually it's
guaranteed to contain a three
progression
um so it's saying like this is sort of
some combinatorial structure which is
unavoidable in in any dense set and he
showed this for some density threshold
which is like one over log log n
and since then there's been a bunch of
work on the problem like all proving a
theorem of the exact same sort just
trying to improve this quantitatively
um to get this density threshold down as
low as possible
um you know towards the the known lower
bounds
um so yeah so this is the history of the
same problem the um where you have some
dense set a is at least like Delta n
inside the integers one through n and
you're looking for the existence of a
non-trivial three progression
um and yeah okay so here like there's
like some minor improvements even
between these so I don't want to say
this is uh everything but roughly you
know there's a big Leap Forward
um early on
um that got us to like you know this one
over uh poly log n
and then you can see that the results
after that are getting closer and closer
to this it's like a one over login
barrier I'll call it I'll talk about
more you know why that's a was a barrier
um
for a while in a second until you know
just recently
um blumen to zask were able to push past
this like one over login barrier
um and one like nice reason uh you might
like to do that is it like proves the
first non-trivial case of like urdish's
uh conjecture regarding K progressions
in uh dense enough like infinite sets
where that's Quantified using like the
sum of their reciprocals but um roughly
what you need to do that uh is for any
end to go past this like one over login
threshold and uh it's very nice
result by blumens was able to do that
okay so then our result again of the
same exact form qualitatively the the
differences in an improvement in this
density threshold
so it just says that if a is any set
which is dense enough then you must have
some non-trivial three progression and
we get this density which is like this
funny looking
um like
quasi-polynomial in
some parameter function here uh
and
I would say that to get a feel for it
probably the best thing to do is to
compare it to this known lower bound due
to Baron so
um Baron shows that for every end there
there actually is some Set uh with
that's very you know reasonably dense
it's like density uh Delta is two to the
minus log n to the one-half
um and yet it contains no three
progressions
um something interesting to note about
this is like it's substantially better
than like a random set maybe a lot in a
lot of these cases you would expect that
to be um
the extremal example but you could think
about what kind of density you would
need for a random set to have uh no
three progressions
um and it needs to be like substantially
smaller than this so Baron's lower bound
is like a you know much higher than than
a random example
um and then what we're able to do is get
density threshold which is like uh
getting pretty close to it so it's the
first kind of uh bound of the right
shape I suppose
um
okay
yeah and then I'd like to shift to just
uh talking about it in a slightly
different way where we're actually going
to you know show the existence of many
solutions to this linear equation X Plus
y equals 2z with X Y and Z all in a one
thing uh convenient thing this lets us
do is like forget about the difference
between trivial and non-trivial
solutions like there's there's always uh
only a smallish number of trivial
Solutions so as long as you can just
show that there are many solutions to
this linear equation that guarantees the
existence of some non-trivial solution
so yeah another way to you know the way
I'd prefer to to say
um what we prove is that uh
you have some set a it has like entropy
deficit D then we're getting this 2 to
the minus d uh to the 12 times N squared
solutions to this equation
yeah so
it's also sensible to think about the
same problem
uh over you know some different settings
like so you take any finite abelian
Group G and
um ask the same problem if you have a
dense set in G
um you get a large number of solutions
to this equation uh with X Y and Z all
in the set and like I want to say the
the general we're not like just being
general for the sake of generality it's
like pretty convenient to
um first of all work in the case of
finite abundant groups that's like more
convenient another reason is it like
really emphasizes the abstractness and
of of the techniques like we're really
just using some very basic uh properties
that
um kind of generalize to all finite
billion groups in in a sense although
certain ones are more convenient than
others so you can see here
over like the group which is like the
vector space over a finite field fq to
the N uh we get somewhat better
parameters
um getting like two to the minus D to
the nine uh times this N squared number
of solutions
and
then a follow-up work due to blumen
success showed how to uh like take our
method and implement it very nicely
within any finite billion group and get
uh you know the like roughly the same
number of solutions we get in the
integer case
um this makes sense like the this group
like when you have uh the cyclic group
mod n is roughly equivalent to this
setting
um up to some like tiny difference in
the density parameter translating back
and forth between the two questions
um so yeah one thing I want to say is
like for the rest of the talk I'm mostly
going to focus on this setting uh like
both the very nice case of F Q to the
end and also like using ZN as a proxy
for the integers so okay
yeah okay so let me now
give you my interpretation of like what
I would say is like the analytic
approach to this problem and I'm trying
to leave as many
details unspecified as possible and just
say what the like basic template
um
of like this analytic approaches and so
so what is the approach so we're given
some dense set a
and what you want to do is find some uh
subset a prime which has like the right
number of solutions to this equation by
which I mean like if a prime was like
random roughly okay and then uh
certainly you want a prime to be as
large as possible
so that we you know get the strongest
conclusion to the the problem we want to
solve that we find many tree
progressions within a and traditionally
what has been tried are subsets a prime
of the following form
um
which is just like the Restriction of a
to some highly structured uh set B so
here's some options for V
um B could be a subgroup
or here's some more General things you
could consider letting B be like a
translate of a bore said or also like a
generalized arithmetic progression so
I'll give it some tiny example about the
what the you know what a bore set is in
a second if you're not familiar with it
um
but yeah roughly I want to say that
they're
reasonable reasonable things to call
approximate subgroups at least like in a
quantitative sense
now
yeah so
if you this first option would certainly
be the nicest like if you could just
actually uh consider restrictions to
subgroups but like maybe you're in a
group like ZN where N is a prime and you
just have no subgroup so certainly uh
that's not going to do anything for you
um so in that case that like that's the
reason why in general finite billion
groups we need to consider some
approximate subgroups like more sets
like which are always present regardless
of the group
um but in this nicer case that I talked
about like F2 to the N we can uh carry
out this plan just thinking about
subgroups
yeah and so here's just like a picture
of it I'm saying uh take our set a we
consider the Restriction of a to some
reasonably large set B where this
restriction becomes uh well behaved so
now like this restriction a prime has
like a predictable number of solutions
and we're able to control it uh for some
reason so yeah okay so it's not this is
a summary of the analytic approach
um the this is like the kind of control
you would like uh and here and for the
rest of the talk Epsilon is going to be
some small constant that doesn't depend
on anything else we'll have some
parameters that depend on the density of
a but Epsilon will always just be some
small constant that's not depending on
anything else
and okay so the yeah this is what we
would like to do this is the analytic
approach and
um yeah let me say just a small example
of like uh what are these approximate
subgroups like what do they look like at
least uh
one example
um so one example is just like an
interval
um
in say the integers
and I can tell you like uh quantitative
justification for why you could say that
this is an approximate subgroup so for
generic sets
of integers if you look at this set of
all sums of pairs of elements from s
then
um the like generic thing to get is
you'll the number of results
you see is roughly s squared okay but
then in contrast here if you take the
subset of the interval with itself you
know it's only doubling in size rather
than squaring so like in some
quantitative senses it's fair to say
that this set is like approximately
closed under addition and that's the
kind of property that we need
um for these approximate subgroups for
the the approach to be carried out
foreign
yeah so here
point of this slide again is to
summarize everything which I'm saying is
like an analytic approach to this
problem a small aside for people that
are familiar with it is that I'm just
like completely trying to ignore the
algebraic approaches like for the capset
problem uh like complicates the story
even more but um
okay so finally I can tell you like the
the way I wanted to try to organize all
these previous results as well as our
result
um typically if you have any
instantiation of this
analytic approach I just talked about
you can like do it anywhere you could do
it here uh in fq to the N with subgroups
and then you could also do it you know
in less nice groups with approximate
subgroups okay like it might be more
painful but like you can just try to
implement roughly morally the same plan
in in either case and
um yeah one main major thing I wanted to
highlight is that a lot of the previous
works
uh were working on something which is
kind of like a orthogonal even to to
what we do in our work which is to try
to take this basic approach
um due to Roth
and like implement it in this nastier
regime where you have to use approximate
subgroups but with as little uh overhead
as possible
okay
um and
with that kind of perspective in mind it
makes sense why like you wouldn't expect
to go past like one over log n that's
like the dream scenario
um if you're just using the nicest
possible
um
kind of class of nice uh group nice sets
V which are subgroups
um like all these works are not even
like attempting to do anything besides
uh you know get as close to this
um as possible like albeit using
approximate subgroups
Okay so
um with that in mind yeah my point is
there have been relatively few
improvements on just like the basic
approach in the analytic setting
um so another one was due to Bateman and
cats and they get this like one over log
n to the one plus C where C is some
small constant
um
in in this setting so they have like a
new basic approach and then like even
you know this one uh introduce a bunch
more complications and like to Port that
over to the general case uh was a big
task and like especially somehow you
need to do it without losing this tiny
constant C so like that makes it even
harder and yeah blumens has asked were
able to do that
um like in contrast uh we are able to so
we get this Improvement which is like a
big Improvement
um already to the basic approach as
implemented in this uh more basic
setting and we have a lot more room to
lose uh when we need to translate it
over
um and I'll say certainly
um in translating it over we use a lot
of technology which were which was
developed in these uh
you know earlier works that were focused
on this problem specifically and how to
translate an argument
um from using subgroups to approximate
subgroups so as efficiently as possible
maybe see if anyone has any questions at
this point it's like a good stopping
place for a second
okay so let me return to yeah my
template that I had for what is the
analytic approach and we need to talk
about a detail that needs to be
instantiated here so certainly
um to be able to do this we need some uh
property that we are hoping for a prime
to actually uh have and uh
yeah but what that's going to correspond
to is some sort of definition for like a
pseudor Randomness which is sufficient
for the application we have in mind okay
so let me just say
um
what is the notion of pseudor Randomness
that we'd like so here this is for just
a an arbitrary set within a finite
Building Group
um so you can imagine drawing two
elements a and a prime uh just uniformly
at random and then you say that this is
our condition for for the set a being
pseudorandom is that if this random
variable a plus a prime is near uniform
so we'll talk a little bit about how
exactly I want to quantify that but yeah
this is like uh basically
um capturing how we want to measure
whether a set is nice or not is if
um adding up two random elements from
the set is giving you a random variable
over G which is roughly uniformly
distributed
and yeah so I don't know you can see the
the definition it's only sensible for
like dense sets certainly if you had a
set of size like less than square root G
then you're never going to get something
like this but yeah for dense sets it's a
reasonable definition of pseudor
Randomness
and let's see why it's useful for the
application
so here yeah I'll just write D of x to
be like this PDF of this random variable
I just talked about and we're comparing
this density function
um to the uniform density function which
is like was just one everywhere over G
that's like our normalization okay so
um
and so this density function D can like
wiggle up and down and like the maybe
this is the best thing that we would
hope for is that uh
is that D is actually just point wise
close like uh plus or minus one plus or
minus Epsilon to the uniform density
function
um it's a very strong condition but
we'll see at least at the very least
that it's sufficient for the application
so what is this telling you
uh it's telling you that um for any set
you know C the number of solutions to
this equation a plus a prime equals c
it's roughly what you'd expect if all
three sets were random uh up to this you
know multiplicative one plus or minus
Epsilon constant factor which is
certainly good enough for us
okay and then so yeah in particular
right you can instantiate this with this
set G which is like the uh
like a dilated by two which is like the
same size as a and um
yeah and then we're getting the number
of solutions is roughly what like a a
cubed over G uh
times some constant factor which is
certainly plenty okay so this is like
the first attempt I'll say that that
will be a little bit too difficult to
actually obtain so you need to weaken
this a little bit
um so now I'm allowing D to deviate
outside this one plus or minus Epsilon
band uh rarely Okay so
um what I want is that this set of
points where it deviates
um the density of that set to be like 2
to the minus P for some parameter p
okay
um and yeah we can see like what kind of
control does this give you for different
values of P well okay
um remember our set a
it's like entropy deficit is d right the
size is two to the minus D times G and
the the set C is the same size okay so
if you set P to be just slightly larger
than D then
um then you know the the set C is like
double the size of this bad set so
um you know
you don't have C just concentrated on
the bad side you're getting plenty of uh
of points where the density function is
like what you would expect and then in
this case we get like you know some
constant Factor also uh within the
number of solutions we would hope for so
um yeah so so yeah here's this uh new
parameter P roughly you can imagine that
we're just always wanting to set P to be
close to D for the application although
for the rest of the talk I'll keep them
separately separate so that we can just
see uh
how things depend on on the density as
well as our choice of this parameter for
the pseudor randomness condition
okay and then something which like I
hope you just believe me on
um
this condition that I talked about where
it's like this Epsilon Delta condition
where you're within this constant band
one plus or minus Epsilon except for
some small uh fraction Delta which is
like two to the minus P points can be
roughly captured by this um P Norm
condition as well uh it's like a small
loss to translate back and forth between
those two ways of thinking about it but
um
in certain contexts it's more convenient
to think about it in one way or the
other I'd encourage you to use like
whichever uh
definition you like
um but we're just remember that it's
like roughly equivalent to the other one
when it whenever I'm uh switching
between them so yeah so I'm saying again
this is like the P Norm distance from D
to the uniform density function and
we're wanting that to be like you know
roughly at most Epsilon which is like a
constant
and yeah okay here's just a tiny bit of
notation that I want to use
um for the entropy deficit of a set
um it's just like you know a set is this
size two the minus D times the group
then then I'm saying that the entropy
deficit of a is equal to D okay
um so here
we get to like what you could consider
to be the main Lemma of the proof and
this is for General groups
yeah so it's saying that you have some
dense set of the group The entropy
deficit is at most D then we have this
dichotomy either the set a is
pseudorandom in the um in the sense that
we just discussed
okay
or we get some density increment of a
onto some highly structured set of V
which is like some approximate subgroup
I haven't talked uh quite yet about why
that's useful but the this is like the
the bulk of the work of the paper is to
show this kind of thing right if we're
in the case one we're happy we get the
number of uh solutions that we are
hoping for
and then the case two this helps us in
some way which I'll talk about in just a
second and then yeah so the other thing
to note is that um
right the entropy deficit the of the
approximate subgroup it depends on our
original entropy depths that it blows up
by some polynomial Factor
yeah so I'm actually gonna I'll very
quickly give another version of this for
for finer fields and then yeah
uh we also get density increment if you
have too many say three term mathematic
progressions for example yes in fact
that's uh easier we'll talk about that
in a second
um in some sense that's like a better
assumption to make
um but also like that is included in
this like I right so our definition of
uh pseudor Randomness does have the
upper and lower bound even though for
the application you only need the lower
boundary we are getting like this uh
control in both directions
yeah so sorry I I can just skip to the
uh this version of it which oh it still
doesn't have okay uh at the very end
I'll get a a good version of this that
has the dependence on everything but uh
this has a d to the four times P to the
fourth
in this case
so yeah in any case it's polynomial in
in the two parameters we care about D
and P that has some dependence on
Epsilon but Epsilon is like a constant
um yeah great
okay so here is just the same thing this
main Lemma visualized showing you you
know what's happening in these two cases
so either this uh PDF right of the
random variable a plus a prime is near
uniform in this way that we talked about
um
or we have the second case like I'm
drawing it like this I guess uh which is
you know this is the
over here is the pseudorandom case this
is like the structured case so in the
structured case we can find some
reasonably large set V
uh that's also highly structured where
we get this density increment
um by like a constant factor that you
know our function is uh going above this
uh uniform density function by like some
constant Factor uh
and okay unlove fairly large 70. so
what is our plan for this second case uh
it's like
in a sense to zoom in on this structured
part okay now right now uh I think
that's a fair way of thinking of it
right now I'm like conflating the
difference between the density function
d and a itself however it's actually
like better to get uh this kind of thing
that I'm drawing here uh like by
averaging that means that there's some
translation some translation of the
where you get the density increment uh
that you needed
Okay so
um let me come back to that let me just
talk about the density increments
um more specifically yeah so so this is
the plan uh just to
finally instantiate all the parts of
this analytic approach that we're going
to use
um so we have our initial set a zero
which we set equal to a we have our
initial nice container set B which is
like the whole Space okay and then at
each step we see is a pseudorandom if it
is we get many three progressions
um because that's like how the
quantification of pseudor Randomness was
designed to to guarantee that okay
so otherwise we get some density
increment okay so we're passing to some
subset zooming in on some a i plus one
which is just the Restriction of AI to
some large uh nice set VI so in this
case it's a it's actually a Subspace
or Now find Subspace and then
okay so since we get a constant Factor
density increment at each step this
proves that um we cannot be in this
second case too many times in a row like
uh eventually we're going to have to
fall into this first case just because
uh the density that we started with was
like 2 to the minus D and it's growing
by this constant Factor that's showing
you that you cannot iterate this more
than like d over Epsilon times before
you must be in the first case instead of
the second case and then that's getting
you um
like this overall uh
quantity D to the nine which is related
to what I quoted at the beginning
um right we're finding a large subset of
a a t of entropy deficit D to the nine
and within a t you're getting like the
same number of three progressions as you
would expect for a random set
let me just go back to show the main
Lemma instantiated for the simple case
so this is like you know over fq to the
n
um yeah so certainly I'll point out that
uh like the three progression problem
doesn't really make sense over F two but
uh this statement does like it's a
non-trivial statement which is
interesting uh over F2 to the N by
itself so if you like I'd encourage you
to just think of Q is equal to two
um however it's also interesting for
constant Q or even like Q is like poly
en still a reasonably interesting
statement um
it's like the theorem is holds for all q
but for a large enough Q uh compared to
the little n um it starts to be not
interesting
so yeah just to go over what is the main
Lemma um that we need to prove it's uh
saying that you have some dense set a of
fq to the N the entropy deficit is like
d
and it's telling you that either the PDF
of a plus a prime is near uniform like
we would like or we get some density
increment onto some large Alpine
Subspace uh with co-dimension which is
like d today
off
foreign
yeah okay so let me just um
try to highlight there's two main ideas
I guess that go into the proof and
here's the first one
um
we call it a spectral positivity and
the first thing that I need to do uh
it's like a small step that's important
for the argument but it's not like the
main point I think here which is
the following observations so we're
looking at our
density function
of the random variable a plus a prime
and uh
did I skip a
yeah okay I did okay sorry great
let me talk about this first sorry about
that
um yeah so let me just go over so
hopefully you believe me like
everything that we need to do to solve
the problem has been reduced to proving
this kind of statement and then for the
rest of the talk I'm just going to talk
about this nice case fq to the end
hopefully you also uh have been
convinced that uh like if you can get
something there then you can do
something more complicated and and get
things working over uh more General
groups as well
subset of the natural number yeah so um
like the
theorem that we get does only apply to
finite billion groups
although like you can embed that into
some cyclic group Without Really any
loss at all so the the point is that if
you had um like the integers one through
n you can embed into like uh z3n
um in such a way that you do not get any
new solutions to this equation that
we're not already present okay so it's
like allowed to do that and then you
solve the problem there and and then if
you get many solutions there then that
tells you you had many solutions in the
original case
okay but uh yeah even if you had like a
cyclic group you may need to do
something it's not like a Subspace it's
like a bore set or a generalized
progression like I had talked about
earlier
um I guess I could say
that in our actual paper
uh we do
like
in a sense it's possible to describe the
algorithm the density increment
algorithm that we use without embedding
into finite groups
um like we are just taking
um in
uh mostly on a sense uh density
increments onto generalized arithmetic
progressions whose rank is uh increasing
slowly okay like um
and that's a sensible statement that you
can just do in the integers without
um you know it makes sense it and you
can do it and it just happens to be that
our analysis still needs to embed things
into into the group so that's like a
little bit different than like embedding
to the into the group and then like your
algorithm is also talking about the
group
so anyway
um
okay
yeah so
now I'm just going to go over
what do you need to do to prove this
main Lemma that hopefully you believe it
is the important point and all you need
to do to finish the proof so
um so what is the setup so it's like
what you would expect
um we have this uh probability density
function of the random variable a plus a
prime okay we're assuming we're not in
the good case which is the case where
it's near uniform where so in particular
we're assuming that D is somewhat
different than the uniform density
function and that this difference is
detectable to the P Norm
okay
and then I mean this is just writing
down like what we wanted our conclusion
to be
uh but I want you like to reinterpret it
slightly
um well actually maybe I'll get here and
reinterpret it slightly but but what we
uh want to do just
following what we wrote down is find
this density increment of the set a onto
some large structured set B
okay
um but actually we're going to try to do
something stronger which is it's
sufficient
um but we're looking for like a density
increment of the density function D
itself
okay so like by averaging because D is
like a convex combination of
translations of a if you can do this
then like you get a density increment
onto one of the translations of a which
means that a translation of V is a
density increment onto a
so that's the reduction there
um
but yeah I actually want to talk about
this uh I have like a specific interest
in this uh a particular Point here which
is like maybe not that interesting to
too many people so if it doesn't make
sense or you don't care then just ignore
it
um but
yeah one thing I want to point out here
is that this is like somewhat of a leap
of faith of the proof um I don't know
like of a good way to justify why you
should obviously be trying this now I
don't want to say like it's also a leap
of faith that everybody else who's like
worked on the problem is also taken so I
don't want to like claim any special
insight there
um but
yeah it's interesting to note that
there's like a series you're seriously
making a decision about how to proceed
here like pursuing something which is
sufficient but not obviously necessary
um
however like I can tell you why it would
be nice if it were possible I can
justify that in a sense okay so
um the reason is
that like now look at what we're what
we're asked to do like our assumption is
some assumption about
the density function D and we're now
seeking like a conclusion about the
density function D like our assumption
is that uh D is differs from the uniform
distribution and this difference is
detectable to the P Norm
I want to say that actually this
difference from the uniform distribution
is detectable by a large Subspace so
that's like the the way that you can
think about the problem now which is I
don't know already sort of a bit nicer
um a second way you could
um
talk about what you've gained by uh
making this decision is the following so
the
theorem that we're after like the main
Lemma it falls under
um like a general class of results which
are called inverse problems where you
make some assumption about the
convolution of like a set a with itself
and you seek a conclusion about a so
that's like what makes it an inverse
problem is uh that you would like to
pull back some statement about the
convolution and and conclude something
about a
um so like here just from a like proof
mechanical perspective I think it's
interesting
um that we've already sort of um
completely suppressed the fact that
we're working on like an inverse problem
like uh if you think that this should be
possible then like I'm no longer need to
worry about a like I don't need to
unpack D anymore
um that's like done in this very simple
argument I just uh talked about but uh
yeah like once you make this step you
decide to pursue this thing I don't need
to unpack D anymore I just need to make
an assumption regarding D and like I'm
seeking a conclusion regarding d
okay so yeah let me talk about uh what
one of the two main ideas that we had
so this is like a small prerequisite to
the first idea I don't think it's like
super essential itself but uh well it's
maybe essential I I don't know it's not
the main point
um but
what I want to do is introduce this
other uh probability density function
it's like instead of taking a plus a
prime and looking at that random
variable we're looking at this you know
somewhat different random variable which
is a minus a prime
and yeah the first observation is just
like that it turns out uh that the P
Norm distance from uniform of f is is
never smaller than D so we can just like
go from D to f
uh and then try to do the same thing we
were hoping to do for f like this for
the same reason it will be just as good
uh f is also like a convex combination
of translates of a so that's just as
useful but yeah uh and this like you can
prove this basically using like koshy
Schwartz in the Fourier domain uh
but um yeah okay so that's one
prerequisite and then
uh now we get to like the main point
um I would say the main point is that
like if F looks like this then that's
bad
um so let me try to talk about what I
mean by that
so f it's promised by our assumption to
deviate from the uniform density
function
uh and that deviation is detectable to
the P Norm
uh but for like generic density
functions
um a large deviation downwards does not
imply a large deviation upwards now like
because we're normalizing around one
like this is centered around one and it
is a density function like in the one
Norm it is true uh the like the same
amount of deviation you have downwards
is is the amount you have upwards okay
so but like as you increase P that
becomes less true and you can think like
there's some vet like the bad example is
you have like a uniform density function
over some large set that's like it's
size like one minus two the minus p
uh fraction of your set
uh so what does that look like it's like
you know uh you have some just tiny tiny
uh increase over the uniform density
function and then it goes like all the
way down to zero
and it just turns out that uh like f
just can't look like that
um like that's
[Music]
um
yeah that's what we're that's what the
claim is here this is the main point of
the observation is that the as measured
by the P normally the magnitude of
deviate total deviation downwards it's
never more than the magnitude of the
total deviation upwards which is like
really important for the whole story
right like at the end of the day we
would like to
witness a density increment
of the of the function okay that's what
we are after now like even more
stringently we need to find a witness
which is like a structured set B but
certainly like disregarding the fact
that you would like it to be structured
there needs to be some large Set uh
where you have a you know deviation
upwards from the uniform density
function otherwise if you're like uh
yeah completely no uh
plan so yeah it was very important that
this is actually uh this is true it's
just um some fact
about uh spectrally positive density
functions so density functions whose
Fourier coefficients are all
non-negative is that they just have to
be like sort of bouncy in this way that
they they can't look like the thing on
the left they have to look like the
thing on the right
um
and yeah it's like more generally true
um for you know yeah uh I guess positive
semi-definite matrices actually it's not
even really uh necessarily a fact just
about uh
functions over a billion groups
is that we have some sort of positive
correlation going on which guarantees
that the amount of deviation downwards
is never more than the amount of
deviation upwards
okay
this is like
the first main idea I would say
yeah now let me talk about the second
main idea
um
that's supposed to come after that's
fine uh
let me just tell you something which I
hope you might believe me about which is
that somehow right we're trying to deal
with this dichotomy
um or trying to prove a dichotomy like
that they're that either your
pseudorandom in the way that we expected
or you're like substantially structured
in this way that we need and like you
know implicitly the point is that
there's nothing in the middle that's
like too bad to be pseudo-random but not
good enough to be structured to kind of
Might imagine that the hard case uh that
needs to be handled is this case where a
is like roughly pseudorandom but it has
some like planted structured part uh
that you need to somehow detect okay
it's like what's causing all the
problems and you need to find it
um so here I think you know it turns out
that like thinking of some plan which
can address this case turn uh is able to
roughly solve the whole thing
um just if a is itself a Subspace
um you know you
you take the union of a Subspace and
then like a random set which is somewhat
larger than the Subspace actually it
could be like a lot larger
even if the random part is a lot larger
it's very possible
for the structured part to be like
responsible for the majority of the
contribution to this uh the norm
um the P Norm distance of our density
function from one
I'm saying yeah but roughly you need
some plan for how do you uncover this
like uh planted Subspace
in this example and this is the the plan
that we use is that you take a and and
consider uh various shifts of a by some
uh by some you know group elements S1
through
I guess we just have one and two here
but uh and then you consider their
intersection and then what's the point
um of this is It's supposed to you know
in the intersection like all the random
part dust is supposed to die and then
you're left over you know you haven't
found uh the entire hidden Subspace but
you've found like some reasonable sized
uh subset of it and and that's what you
need uh okay so
yeah this is that's the main idea and
then I'll say like a little bit more
specifically what are we actually doing
um
so
yeah again let's look at this density
function and by this uh
stuff we've already talked about uh we
can actually assume like that it that f
deviates from the uniform density
function in this sense like that the P
Norm is at least one plus Epsilon uh you
might have to change like P slightly to
go from what we just talked about to
this but what this is measuring like the
fact that uh F has a substantial amount
of deviation upwards from the uniform
density function
okay
um so under this assumption what are we
actually sifting to find in the general
case like that's not just this specific
example
um we're using sifting to find the set B
it it's like of the form we talked about
you take multiple uh copies of a shift
them all and then consider their
intersection
and uh the PSI it's important that the
size is large so it's you know if you
started with a set D then the size is
roughly two to the minus DP times a
and what does it do
it Witnesses this deviation upwards from
uniform in the following sense like the
convolution of B with itself
specifically is what I mean
it Witnesses this deviation upwards from
uniform
and remember like what whatever we want
we wanted a highly additively structured
witness we wanted a Subspace so we
haven't gotten there completely but like
we've gotten a step closer so uh
previously we were witness we had in our
hands a witness the only thing we knew
about it was that it was large
okay so this is getting like a baby step
closer to the goal so we we now have a
witness with some additive structure
um
of the
uh deviation upwards from uniform
and yeah so let me I can give you a
summary of the whole thing here
um there's this last step that I didn't
talk about too much roughly uh once you
have this Witness
with some additive structure mild
additive structure
at this point you can use some like
well-known tools to bootstrap this into
like a witness with strict additive
structure and right so here we are
saying that we got this entropy deficit
which is like P times D this
bootstrapping loses you some additional
polynomial factors in both uh pnd but it
gives you an actual uh roughly like just
to say what happens here you take uh
even you're able to pass to like higher
convolutions uh
um
of more than just two sets okay and then
once you take like roughly you know D
convolutions of sets with uh
but yeah if you're like an iterated uh
convolution of D sets then you can use
some foyer analysis to say that that's
actually very close to some Subspace so
uh that that's how you finish the the
last part but here yeah I just wanted to
highlight these are the two main
contributions of the work is first this
idea
um to use spectral positivity to take
our initial witness which is like given
to us just by the Assumption of the
Lemma
um it's like completely unstructured the
only thing we know is that it's somewhat
large and it's somewhat small entropy
deficit
and it guaran it shows you the existence
of some witness s uh which is like
witnessing the deviation upwards
specifically
okay
and then we need to use sifting to go
from this fact to uh a witness which was
somewhat smaller it has entropy deficit
PD now but it has more additive
structure and then you continue this at
like so as we go down we're trading
entropy deficit for additive structure
but at the end we find a highly
additively structured set this Subspace
B
um still with a reasonably small entropy
deficit
that's true although it wasn't important
that it did
what do you mean it's not important
I mean you said that you don't use
anything about the structural bit
but then you would find the according to
the structure okay which
actually find the structure of if so
I see what you mean okay uh
okay
that's a fair point um
so first let me answer the what I
thought we were you were asking about
um which is like it's not important in
the sense that I would be happy to find
anything uh okay that that's all I meant
um
but yeah you're saying is there like an
interpretation of the entire thing which
you actually don't unwrap F ever
that uh might not be entirely true so
like a
in the sense that
yeah you could so F certainly we'd want
to assume it's like non-negative
um but I think even it's possible to
like take the convolution of two
um
functions which are sometimes negative
and obtains the convolution is like
non-negative everywhere uh so this is
like some obstruction to
implementing what we have exactly
because yeah what what do I do
um mechanically to carry it out is I
write down F and like the P power of F
and then I just expand that into like
what is it it's not a convolution itself
but it's like a a weighted sum of some
convolutions of sets that uh that look
like that look like this
um and yeah are you saying can you do it
entirely abstractly that's an
interesting question I've I've tried uh
yeah just to see if you can and I'm not
so sure I think that like certainly some
features are
are not that important like the fact
that um
one thing that's fine is if F was the
convolution of
two density functions which are not
necessarily flat like I I want to say
that's like at least a mild thing you
might uh hope also is fine and that is
fine that's fine uh yeah how
or you can push it I'm not so sure but
um yeah if you want to get something
completely abstract I feel like the fact
that I just talked about uh is like some
barrier to or I don't know it I don't I
don't know how to do it by the by the
same plan at all so yeah
um
okay
so yeah I I guess I mostly did get my
summary of this whole thing uh the way
that I wanted to interpret it is maybe
like depending on your background you
might appreciate the following analogy
that like in a sense it's it's uh
similar to like rounding you know a semi
definite program or something like uh at
the beginning you're given some uh like
dual witness uh witnessing something and
you would like to say like infer from
that the existence of a more structured
witness and you're willing to like trade
certain things like uh you know the
exact number Epsilon or maybe like the
entropy deficit so yeah as we're going
down here we're imitating a witness
which is more structured uh losing
slightly in the like parameter related
to Epsilon and then also losing in the
entropy deficit oh
but yeah I think that that's a
reasonable summary of the whole thing
yeah thanks everyone
questions
so are there like uh
obstacles to to potentially improving
like the exponent in this bound it's
closer to parent stuff or do you have
like yeah I think that's a really
interesting question I would say uh the
like the most glaring thing is the
following
um even like forgetting like the
analysis where we lose various
polynomial factors in each step like the
basic plan of taking density increments
it's interesting to consider whether
that's like going to sensibly give you
the right answer
um and it's already like
well
it's strange because in like finite
Fields
um you might think like a a typical bad
example to check is like a Hamming ball
um or whatever reason that ends up being
bad I guess because we're like we have
something it's like in between being
additively structured and being like
actually additively structured I don't
know exactly how to justify that but you
can go through the calculations and it
looks like um
okay I didn't talk about this but
um yeah so are you familiar with like
the cap set problem and the parameters
you get there all right so you get some
better parameters better than Baron's
bone so something that I think is
interesting is that like even the best
conceivable implementation that that I
can conceive of this basic plan where
you took density increments it seems to
like never recover that if you just take
density increments you're already
getting like D Squared just like the
plant like even if you had you know no
loss anywhere else
um
but I mean maybe yeah then the other
point is yes like it's maybe conceivable
that you get D Squared like Baron's
bound basically uh if everything else
was like ridiculously tight you had no
loss like you know when we do sifting we
go from D to PD you need like d plus P
when you do uh like this ask and and
this uh bootstrapping stuff you go from
like whatever you have to the fourth
power you'd need like to go from uh you
know again you don't you need no loss
like it's conceivable that you could get
uh D plus P for that as well actually I
don't know if it's I shouldn't say that
I don't know if it's conceivable like uh
it it seems to if you think that the
whole plan should work and you could
roughly analyze it in this way it seems
to imply that like uh
these results could be improved way past
anything that I could like imagine how
to do uh but yeah I mean maybe it's
possible
but exactly the set s which is the
witness for the and
um no so those are unrelated so here
like
you're saying which elements you pick to
shift by it that's what you're asking
um yeah that's an interesting I mean uh
it's certainly not explicit how we're
picking them
um and in fact like you could say that
you're picking them randomly but I think
that that's even like a bit misleading
itself because
um It's like a
first moment method kind of argument so
like some quantity we need like we need
certain quantities to be good we need
like this to happen and we also need
this to happen you can come up with a
quantity which balances both of them and
then apply the first moment method to
that but it really only shows you the
existence okay so I'm like summing over
all possible choices I and I look at
this quantity
and uh I can conclude the existence of
some some choice of s
which worked for everything and like
yeah something that really hammers home
why that it's like
not really fair to think about it at
random is like the exact same
calculation works over like an infinite
size group like I can sum over all that
he had the elements in the whole group
and like do this uh like pigeon oh I'll
do this for first moment uh method type
argument and find the existence of some
choice but yeah I don't know that
How likely you are to find uh as the
ships that work
um so this uh the same idea it's it's
called dependent random sir yes
Theory and you can interpret this I yeah
it's probably worth pointing out that
this is a really powerful course to Muse
sure yeah so that's true I mean uh if
you want to uh look at it exactly uh
like that it takes just a little bit of
um translating things and thinking of uh
these sets as actually specifying some
like you know bipartite graphs or
something but then yeah I agree that
like applying it uh to those bipartate
graphs is exactly uh dependent random
choice
so one great uh
if you look at some other equations like
X plus three y equals two Z plus two w
and you wanna uh
like that it's thought that the exponent
actually should be less than one and
just wondering if any of these economic
ideas can push
backwards
so you mean the next like the next one
of what so if you look at equations and
four variables there are some of them uh
where we don't know that the exponent is
one or not and um and what is the expert
that's a bad time so you're looking at
how large of a subset of one to end can
you get and
you know like see it on sets it's the
largest subset of one through n you can
get is square root of that enough weight
and uh
y equals two Z plus two w you wanna okay
so you're saying yeah
okay you're saying it's conjunction you
can get like cap set like uh parameters
for them exactly but the only thing we
know how to do is basically these types
of methods
yeah so it's a convolution of more
that's what uh roughly like I not sure
if you say it was like four of them it's
an equation of four variables okay
instead of three variables so it's a one
linear equation yeah I mean
um I think it's sensible that uh that
should help substantially like that the
question that I have been thinking about
which is it seems very related I guess
is like just um
um well I was going to say like
polynomial Freeman and Russia but maybe
uh more accurate to say like the
specific approach where you go through
like uh uh but probably about problem
and yeah okay so the problem is to try
to find like a large Subspace within 4A
right
yeah and um you're somehow it needs to
come into your argument that like you're
using for a instead of like 2A I yeah I
actually have some vaguish ideas about
how to actually make use of that but uh
I don't know
I don't know if they're too related to
what I talk I guess they they're
similarly but I'd be happy to talk to
you about that yeah sure
okay you seem to be capable of saying
anything about
sort of want to to balance subsets
[Music]
who's different set of games where
um I would think no I don't think this
is the right uh
like I think this interesting problem
although like that's kind of a problem
in a different sort of about a different
kind of pseudor Randomness and then it's
the essential one here like somehow uh
there you're really trying to understand
like what is the intrinsic uh super
randomness of like the set of squares in
an additive sense and like here we're
more trying to say like what uh well
usually consider Randomness as a tool
but like saying for arbitrary dense sets
we're trying to understand what's the
like most pseudo-random large part of it
you can zoom in on uh so they're a
little bit different in spirit I mean
maybe they could
ultimately be kind of mixed but I
haven't seen anything uh like that
happen I think
okay so let's take any federal questions
offline and let's say things is under
again
[Applause]
we'll return after launcher too